joining me is a retired Air Vice
Marshall Sean Bell Sean great to see you
as always
um so let's touch on this uh this issue
of dwindling supplies of ammunition more
broadly how big a concern is that for
Ukraine ammunition has been uh
inevitably quite topical even though
it's relatively simple but I guess it's
a vital part of any Battlefield at the
moment and I'm trying to get behind the
story a bit is the the key issue here if
we look at some of the statistics
America has donated over a million uh
rounds of the artillery since the start
of the conflict
um but the challenge is that the
production that its industry can provide
is less than a tenth of that so it would
take some years for it to recoup and
even if it surges that industry we're
still looking for several years before
it can recover that those War stocks and
that's before you provide anything else
to Ukraine in the coming year
um now why is this shortfall come about
Well the West had never anticipated that
there'd be a war of this scale of this
duration of this ferocity to happen in
Europe anytime soon and all you of your
defense planning assumptions were based
on much smaller conflicts much more much
smaller in size and scale and ferocity
and therefore War stocks that should
have lasted for years actually are only
lasting four weeks and in some cases
only in in terms of days the Russia's
mode of operation here it's a 20th
century Warfare they have a Year's worth
of artillery rounds because that's how
they fight they've been using 20 000
rounds of artillery a day they don't
care about the devastation that's reeks
behind them whereas Ukraine is a much
smaller country has much smaller stocks
of this ammunition and it's quite
difficult for the West to Source Russian
Artillery rounds so part of this is
making sure that Ukraine is properly
furnished but also because it's not just
about the artillery rounds it's also
about the equipment that fires them and
you need to provide spare support and
stuff like that and bluntly the West has
not always provided the most modern
equipment to Ukraine and therefore there
is quite a sustainment tell that's
associated with that so is there that a
separate issue about replacing uh or
just giving in the first instance the
kind of more complicated equipment not
just the the ammunition definitely what
the West does not want to do is for
Ukraine to be dragged into a slugging
match a grinding uh War of Attrition on
the ground so the West which fights 21st
century warfare using Precision weapons
uh and and the light is aiming to reduce
collateral damage reduce the um
implications for lies for soldiers and
particularly for civilians and that's
what we provide to Ukraine Ukrainian
support has been it's been decisive
because not only they've stopped the
Russian advance but they've actually
managed to push the Russians back but
the supply is limited and we'll use a
couple of examples here of why it's
limited this is the U.S
guided multi-launch rocket system that
the Americans provided to Ukraine uh
it's got they've been hitting about 400
targets uh a month and not only do they
provide the equipment they provide the
Rockets as well now at the moment
they've handed over that many in a year
their industry is able to provide about
that same number a year so it's
sustainable and if industry was to Surge
it's about double a number so this is a
sustainable way of supporting Ukraine
however if you look at Javelin which is
another example that's an American anti
tank weapon the Americans provided eight
and a half thousand of these are in the
war and they've stopped providing them
now because their war starts have got to
a level which the Americans are worried
it will compromise their ability to do
Wars elsewhere this is the level the
industry can provide it'll take a decade
to build up and even if they surge we're
talking about about many years I was
just gonna say very quickly the U.S
keeps what level back in in the U.S 10
times this amount that they've given
away very difficult the levels of
Warstock are intensely secret because
they're all based on rates of effort and
how much you're going to keep in the
available for a war what we do know
though is that it's very unusual for the
Americans to stop providing support this
has hit a critical number but it's also
aware that even in the UK we gave 10 000
n law missiles which are interested the
key message here though bluntly is
Russia has put its industry onto a war
footing at the moment NATO and the UK
are simply opening a cupboard seeing
what's there and provide hiding it
eventually NATO will have to find a more
sustainable model together with industry
to provide Ukraine with a quantity and
the quality of material it needs to win
this war Sean fascinating as always
thanks